THE GLOBAL ECONOMY OFFICER
RECOVERS TO LOWER PRICES FOR
CONSUMER.
>> A PERSON SAID TEXAS COULD
PRODUCE THAT OIL IF YOUR
ADMINISTRATION WILL STAY OUT OF
THE WAY.
WHEN WE REACH ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE WE DON'T HAVE TO
KISS THE RING OF OPEC.
WE CAN LIVE CHEAPER AND CLEANER.
HE IS REVERSING IT.
>> NO, THAT'S CONFUSEED.
>> OKAY.
HOW DARE YOU.
>> THIS YEAR PRODUCTION OF OIL
IN THE U.S. WILL AVERAGE OVER 11
MILLION A DAY IN THE YEAR.
>> WHY IS HE BEGGING OPEC FOR
HELP?
>> HE IS DOING WHAT PRESIDENT
TRUMP DID IN 2019.
WHAT PRESIDENT BUSH DID BEFORE
THAT AND PRESIDENT CLINTON
BEFORE THAT, WHICH IS, THERE ARE
A LOT OF DISPUTES WITHIN OPEC.
DURING THE PANDEMIC SOME OF THE
COUNTRIES TRIED TO CUT BACK
PRODUCTION BECAUSE THEY THOUGHT
THE PRICE WAS GETTING TOO LOW.
THE U.S. PRESIDENT PUT PRESSURE
ON OPEC TO GIVE WAY TO THE OPEC
MEMBERS THAT WANT TO INCREASE
THE AMOUNT OF PRODUCTION.
I DO THINK POLITICALLY IT'S
A TOUGH SPOT.
WHEN THE PRICE OF GAS GOES UP.
PEOPLE THINK THIS IS THE
PRESIDENT'S FAULT BUT IT'S
BECAUSE OF U.S. POLICY THAT IS
NOT CORRECT.
THE ECONOMY BACK PEOPLE THAN
PEOPLE THOUGHT IT WOULD.
WE HAVE RESTRICTION OF SUPPLY
AND THE DEMAND IS TOO HIGH.
>> BRIAN, WE KILLED THE
PIPELINE.
THAT COST THOUSANDS OF JOBS.
THIS DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
TO KILL A PIPELINE AND ASK FOR
HELP.
>> AND THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
PRESIDENT BUSH AND CLINTON AND
OTHERS WHO SAID START PUMPING
MORE.
YOU HAD A GUY 2 DAYS PRIOR RIDE
AROUND IN A ELECTRIC CAR AND WE
WILL MAKE THE COMBUSTION ENGINE
OLD NEWS.
IF YOU GO TO TEXAS WHERE THEY
HAVE LEASES IN NEW MEXICO AND
THEY CAN'T DRILL THERE BECAUSE
IT'S FEDERAL LAND.
THEY DESTROYED THAT INDUSTRY.
AUSTIN, IF YOU SAY WE ARE
DRILLING AT THE SAME RATE, I
HAVE NOT CHECKED THE BARREL
RATES TODAY BUT I HAVE SEEN A
LOT OF CRASHING.
YOU HAVE NO RIGHT TO TALK TO
OPEC 2 DAYS AFTER TELLING
EVERYBODY THAT OIL AND GAS ARE
DESTROYING THE WORLD.
NOW ASKING FOR A FAVOR.
>> THAT'S A GREAT FOUNTH.
-- POINT.
MARTHA?
>> YOU CHANGE THE TONE WHEN YOU
STOP GIVING FEDERAL LEASES FOR
NATURAL GUESS.
WE HAD REACHED ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE IT WAS
EXTRAORDINARY AND NOT BE RELIANT
ON FOREIGN SOURCES.
IT PUT US IN A DIFFERENT
POSITION.
MADE IT CLEAR TO OTHER COUNTRIES
WE WERE DETERMINED TO FIND OUR
OWN SOURCES OF DRILLING, TO
EXPAND THE PIPELINE
AVAILABILITY.
THAT MESSAGE HAS REVERSED.
THAT MESSAGE IS NO LONGER WHERE
PEOPLE VIEW THE AMERICAN
APPROACH TO ENERGY.
>> DAGEN MCDOWELL, YOU WERE HOT
ON THIS STORY YESTERDAY.
TELL ME WHY AUSTIN IS WRONG?
>> EVERYTHING THAT COMES OUT OF
HIS MOUTH IS WRONG.
JUST KIDDING.
BEAR WITH ME.
A WHITE HOUSE OFFICIAL SAID WE
WILL PUSH FORWARD WITH OUR
AMBITIOUS CLIMATE AGENDA BUT WE
ARE ALSO GOING TO TRY TO STOP
THIS TEMPORARY SURGE IN GAS
PRICES BY BEGGING OPEC TO
PRODUCE MORE.
THIS ILLUSTRATES HOW FAKE THEIR
GREEN ENERGY POLICY IS.
IT'S MORONICAL FOR THEM TO DO
THIS.
YOU ARE DISCOURAGING PRODUCTION
HERE, BUT THEN YOU ARE
ENCOURAGING IT ELSEWHERE.
THAT SERVES ZERO PURPOSE IN
FIGHTING CLIMATE CHANGE.
IT'S CALL GLOBAL WARMING BECAUSE
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THE GLOBE.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THE WORLD.
WHERE A BARREL OF OIL IS
PRODUCED IS IRRELEVANT.
WHERE THAT TAIL PIPE IS, IS
IRRELEVANT.
IF YOUR RATIONALE IS TO FIGHT
GLOBAL WARMING.
THIS MANEUVER HAS ZERO IMPACT ON
TOTAL FUEL CONSUMPTION.
>> IF YOU PROMOTE ELECTRIC CARS
THERE IS LESS DEMAND FOR OIL.
THAT DOESN'T RAISE THE PRICE OF
OIL.
IT REDUCES THE PRICE OF OIL.
THAT'S THE ARGUMENT FOR THE
GREEN REVOLUTION.
>> YOU PROMOTE ELECTRIC VEHICLES
AND TRY TO REDUCE FRACKING AND
THE PRODUCTION OF NATURAL GUESS
IN THIS COUNTRY USED TO PRODUCE
THE ELECTRICITY YOU NEED TO
CHARGE THESE CARS?
I COULD BELCH A BETTER ENERGY
POLICY.
>> PLEASE DON'T.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> WHO REALLY BENEFITS FROM OUR
GREEN ENERGY POLICYS?
CHINA?
>> YES.
>> WE ARE BETTER OFF PRODUCING
OIL HERE.
THEY EMITMORE POLLUTION TO
PRODUCE THE SAME AMOUNT OF FUEL.
THE FUEL WILL GO ON SHIPS TO
CHINA WHO IS BUILDING ENOUGH
COAL FIRE PLANTS TO POWER ALL OF
GERMANY.
THAT'S POLLUTION.
>> IS THERE A FREE MARKET WAY TO
GET ELECTRIC CARS?
>> IF THERE WAS A WAY TO DO IT,
THEY WOULD DO IT.
>> YOU TAX G